for this shopkeeper in dakar the
presidential inauguration of alfa conde
is another step back for democracy in
his home country guinea
mustafa bade looks concerned as he
watches the head of guinea's
constitutional court
praised the 86 year old president's
eagerness to take on a third term
he says he's not duped and has kept a
tally of all that has gone wrong since
kante came to power ten years ago
from tweaking the constitution to allow
him to stay in power
to rampant corruption and arresting
opponents in a country rich in minerals
like gold and bauxite
most ghanaians are trapped in poverty
baldi says
conde is failing his people at the
beginning we thought alfa conde would
bring us hope
but he has shown us his true colors he
has disappointed us
he doesn't respect the constitution and
he exercises control of
everything people are scared of him they
are either getting arrested
or killed after his victory was
announced in october the military fired
live bullets at protesters and went
house to house detaining mostly people
from the
fulani ethnic group who support
opposition candidate celut dalengalo
he believes conde rigged the elections
and says he won the vote
the inauguration is taking place as
protests are being held
gathered during the ceremony are a
number of aging african heads of state
who like conde have changed their
country's constitution to stay in power
outside of baldi's shop are young
african migrants from
various french-speaking african
countries all of them share this common
feeling that they've left behind
nations led by aging presidents clinging
on to power
robbing their nation's wealth and
leaving young people without jobs
opportunities and the space and freedom
to express their political views at the
cars museum of black civilization the
activists from across the continent have
gathered
to warn of a dangerous trend of civil
liberties being stifled
and governments muffling democracy and
freedom of expression among those taking
part
is ibrahimovialo an outspoken critic of
conde conde's government
has issued an international arrest
warrant against him
initially
we have seen the nation state use the
global coronavirus pandemic as an excuse
to restrict individual
and collective freedoms of citizens
banning protests when these do not suit
governments
this pandemic is benefiting autocratic
regimes
the borders between guinea and senegal
are closed valde is unable to return
home to his
family and with the inauguration of
alphaconde
he fears there will be more trouble
ahead nicholas hawk
al jazeera dakar